Hi everybody.
I'm Eric Leichtenschlag
from the AdMob
Developer Relations Team.
And today, I'm here to talk to
you about DFP Showcase v2.
So to start off, you
might all be
wondering what is DFP Showcase.
DFP Showcase is a sample app
that features the different
creative types offered by
DoubleClick for Mobile,
DoubleClick for Publishers
Mobile, both bundled and
premium features.
To the right here, you see a
screenshot of what the version
one app looked like with a set
of eight examples here.
And what does v2 include?
Well, v2 adds support for
additional creative types such
as MRAID banners, Mobile Image
Carousel ads, video
interstitials on Android.
And we also are more explicit
about the categorization
between bundled features offered
to DFP Publishers for
Small Business and premium, to
creative types which are
offered to DFP premium
Publishers.
So now that we know what the
project is all about, let's
walk through how to build it.
So if you're trying to build
this on Android, you're going
to need the Android SDK
installed with the latest
system image.
We recommend the latest image.
You don't actually
need the latest.
We prefer the Eclipse
development environment, or if
you use InnteliJ, that's
fine as well.
And you'll want to download
the DFP Showcase Android
version two Sample Project from
our Google Mobile Dev
Google Code Project as well
as the Google AdMob Ads
SDK from our Docs.
If you're on iOS, you want to
make sure you have Xcode 4.5
installed as well as an iOS
version 4.3 or higher.
And you'll want to download
the iOS version of the DFP
Showcase App as well as the
Google AdMob Ads SDK for iOS.
So currently, the
Android version
has just been released.
And so we're going to walk
through that today.
The iOS version will be
coming out shortly.
The implementation is
pretty similar.
So to build the project, we're
just going to import the
sample app that we downloaded
into our workspace, add the
Google AdMob SDK library that
you also downloaded, and just
run the app.
That's all that's required.
So I have an empty Eclipse
workspace here.
I'm going to go to File, New
Project, Import a Project from
Existing Code.
And I already have it
downloaded here.
So I'm just going
to open it up.
Here's our project.
We're also going to want to add
to Google AdMob SDK in the
Libs directory, that way we
don't need to reference it
explicitly in our build path.
So I've added it here.
All the compilers
have gone away.
We should be able to run
this app right away.
So I'm running it on a
Galaxy Nexus emulator
running Jelly Bean.
And it's loading up the app.
And this is what it looks
like on Android.
So we have a list view here.
Well, two list views in a tab
controller here showing all
the different examples.
If we click through, for
example, just a basic image,
we'll just come to an image
activity and it will
load the image ad.
We can go to some more
complex examples like
Mobile Image Carousel.
And here, we're getting a
bigger a 300 by 250 ad--
or we should.
Here we go--
with multiple images.
And you can swipe through.
You can also click through.
These ads all have clickthrough
URLs.
So this is a Google Glass ad.
And so we'll go to
google.com/glass.
So I'm going to quickly walk
through how this is
implemented on the
native side.
So here's our main activity with
our tab controller here.
We create a tab host, and
we're adding two tabs.
One's going to be for bundled,
one's going to be for premium.
We have our list of constants
here representing each enum.
And the constant here represents
an ad format.
We give it a name, a size, an
icon, and that will be the
icons that you see
on the main page.
So name, size, icon.
As well as an ad unit
that we're using
to make the ad request.
And the actual implementation
checks to see which example
we're running.
It either creates a banner view
or an interstitial with
the appropriate ad unit.
I'll walk through an example
interstitial here.
Let's walk through the mobile
interstitial with auto-close.
So this interstitial will
automatically close after five
seconds because that's
how it was set up.
So that's pretty much
the implementation
on the native side.
But I think what's more
important for DFP Publishers
is how you actually set
it up within DFP.
So we're going to walk through
each of these examples and
talk about how they're
set up in DFP.
So the first example we have
is just your basic image.
I showed it to you already.
We come into Image, and it's
just set up as a 360 by 50
banner here.
So how do we do that in DFP?
Well, this is using
a bundled feature.
So small businesses
can use the Image
Creative Format template.
And all you need to provide
is a clickthrough URL.
So we'll click through
to plus.google.com.
A size.
So this is actually implemented
as a 320 by 50 and
a 360 by 50 so we can support
some of the bigger Android
devices like the Galaxy Nexus
or S3 as well as like the
iPhone 5 who's only 320 wide.
We provide a clickthrough URL,
target the ad unit size, and
we're good to go.
And we get an ad unit, and we
just put that in our app and
make sure we request the correct
size, and we'll get
that served.
The downside of this basic image
template is that you do
not get high-resolution
images.
What that means is if you upload
a 320 by 50 image,
you'll have a 320 by 50
creative, and that's what it
will look like on the screen.
If you wanted to upload
a 640 by 100 image for
high-resolution devices, it
would actually look too big
and it would only show
the top left segment
on the screen here.
That's one of the downsides
of using an image
template like this.
To get around that for
high-resolution images, you'll
have to use a custom template
that you can create or write
some custom code.
And we'll kind of walk through
that later, how you do that.
So the next sample we'll talk
about is an AdMob banner.
So within DFP, you can set
up to backfill to AdMob.
And what this is doing under the
hood is calling into the
Google AdMob SDK and requesting
an AdMob ad.
So how is that done in DFP?
Well, it's set up as AdMob
Creative Type.
And all you need to pass is
your AdMob publisher ID.
And DFP will go and request
the AdMob ad for you.
You also request a target
size, 320 by 50.
In this case, we can't support
360 by 50 because AdMob
doesn't support that as
an explicit size.
DFP requires specific sizes like
320 by 50, 300 by 250,
and has to request a size
that AdMob supports.
Similar to the AdMob example is
the SDK Mediation example.
So you can also implement
AdMob Mediation directly
through DFP.
So in this example, we're
using the SDK Mediation
Creative type.
And we only set up one ad
network here which is AdMob,
and also provided the
publisher ID here.
On the native side, this will
actually go through the
mediation flow, and you could
set up multiple networks if
you wanted to.
We just have AdMob
in this example.
So again, you'll see it'll
look the same.
You'll see an AdMob ad.
But again, you could set up
multiple networks here.
And you can also provide the
timeout, which is how long we
expect AdMob to wait for each
network to come back with a
creative or not.
If it takes too long,
we'll timeout.
So the next example we
have here is just a
text and image ad.
There's a text and
image template.
This is all for small
business.
You just provide, again,
a destination URL, the
headlines, so DFP Showcase ad
is what you see up top.
Two descriptions which
will flip, as well
as the button text.
I think that's if the button's
not available.
And it generates this text
and image ad for you.
So again, in the application,
this is what it looks like.
And we have our text
and image ad.
So this is also set
up as a 320 by 50.
The next example is a DFA tag.
So as a DFP publisher, you
might be working with a
creative agency who sets up
an ad in DoubleClick for
advertisers and just gives
you a DoubleClick tag.
And you'll just go into DFP and
create a DoubleClick tag
template and pass in
the redirect URL.
And it will redirect to the DFA
and serve the DFA ad that
the creative agency gave you.
So in this case, this redirect
URL points to a DoubleClick
ad, also set up as
a 320 by 50.
And we can see it here below.
So the next example we're
showing here is an MRAID
Expandable.
This is actually using a
third-party template where you
actually are writing
your own code.
For this example, we've set up
two different creatives--
one for 320 by 50 and
one for 360 by 50.
And the native application will
determine the screen size
to figure out which one is more
appropriate to request.
And the creative itself is using
media queries to serve
the appropriate assets for
the expanded image.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
And it also uses the MRAID
API to expand the image.
So let's quickly look at what
it looks like in the
application.
In this case, we'll get a 360 by
50 because the Galaxy Nexus
is big enough.
If we click through, it'll
open to an overlay.
This is a one piece
expandable.
And it's serving a 360 by 592
image in this case with some
black borders and the
big image here.
And we can close it.
And we'll walk through the
creative code for this.
So there's a couple things
to look at here.
The big thing to point out
is the media query here.
We're looking at only screens
and the max height of 592,
which represents
a Galaxy Nexus.
Then we'll serve content URL
for a 360 by 592 image.
If the screen is bigger
than that--
so like the S3 has, I think,
640 density pixels high--
then we'll serve the 360
by 640 image here.
So this is how we can have the
creative decide which asset to
serve based on the
screen size.
And that's the basic HTML.
We just have a banner.
When it's clicked, we
call MRAID.expand.
It's using the basic MRAID
API to call expand.
And it's a one piece expendable
because we're not
passing in a parameter here.
Expand can take a URL.
And if you pass that, it'll be a
two piece expandable, and it
will load the new HTML file
that you pass there.
On the JavaScript side, we're
doing a couple things.
We are listening for
state changes.
So when the MRAID state changes,
if it's expanded,
we're setting the banner image
to use the overlay banner.
And the overlay banner will be
one of these content URLs.
And in the default case when
it's not expanded, we're just
using the basic banner which is
a 360 by 50, or the other
creative would have
a 320 by 50 here.
And so when the creative loads,
we're going to add the
event listener for
the state change.
And if it's already in the
default mode, then we're going
to call handle state changes
explicitly to set
the class to banner.
So this is all set up as a
third-party creative template,
and you have to put in all
this code yourself.
The final example that we're
going to show from the bundled
side is an interstitial.
So this is a basic
interstitial.
It's also implemented as
a third-party creative.
But we're serving it as an
interstitial within the SDK.
So in this case, we just have
one third-party creative.
And because it's an interstitial
overlay, the
media queries won't work.
I tested it out, and looks like
the min and max height
can be infinite because
the overlay kind of
spans pass the screen.
So the way we worked around this
here is to, on the native
side, pass some parameters of
the screen size basically to
the creative.
And the creative can read
those and determine
what asset to serve.
This example also uses the
countdown timer and can also
auto close the interstitial.
So this is what it looks like
on both iOS and Android.
You can click the Show
Interstitial button.
And will put in the right
creative based
on the screen size.
So how is this done in code?
Again, we're looking
at JavaScript here.
This top portion shows how to
implement the auto-close.
We have a display counter
of five seconds.
And we'll start the countdown
and basically the number of
seconds times 1,000
milliseconds.
That's how long we'll wait to
call admob.opener.close.
This is part of the Google
Mobile Ads API.
And after that time, we will
call admob.opener.close.
and it will automatically
close the interstitial.
The magic with the multiple
creatives here
is under Set Image.
So we get the screen
width and screen
height via this pattern.
And this pattern screen width
is coming directly from the
native portion of the code,
which is set down here.
So in our ad request, we're
specifying some extras with
the screen width parameter,
which gets the screen width
and density pixels as well
as the screen height.
And we can read those within
a DFP creative by doing
%%pattern colon and then
the extra key name.
So for a Galaxy Nexus, this will
return 360 and 592 as a
screen width and height.
And we're going to get our image
source based on this.
So we're going to default
to a smaller image.
And if the screen height's
more than 640, then we're
going to set the image source
to the 360 by 640 creative.
If the screen height's greater
than 592, we're going to set
it to the 360 by 592 creative.
So in this way, we're able to
serve a different asset using
the same code by checking the
screen width and screen height
that we're expecting from
the native SDK.
So that's it for the
bundled features.
Now I'm going to talk
about the premium
features offered in DFP.
So the first one is Mobile
Image Carousel.
This is set up as a create
template that's pre-defined
called Mobile Image Carousel
App and Web.
You pass in a target size--
in this case, 300 by 250, a
clickthrough URL, the width
and height of the images.
And then you just upload
five images assets.
And DFP will create the
snippet for you.
It's read only, so the creative
code gets essentially
sent to the application.
And I'll show it to you
in the app again.
We get this carousel looking ad
that we can swipe through.
So the advantage with
DoubleClick for Publishers
premium is that you can get
this template for free.
You can actually implement the
same thing with DoubleClick
for Publishers bundled
if you had this code.
So this snippet right here, you
could actually copy and
paste that.
I guess you don't have access
to it if you're not premium
publisher, but you could write
this same code yourself, and
you could host your own
images, and you could
essentially kind of make
the same thing.
But it's kind of roll
your own solution.
Premium gives you these
pre-defined templates which
you can use to set
up these types of
creatives really easily.
The next example I have here
is a mobile image with a
Google +1 button.
So this, again, is another
DoubleClick for Publishers
premium creative pre-defined
mobile image with Google +1
app and web.
Again, you give it an image
asset, a width and height, a
clickthrough URL, and a couple
other parameters.
And it'll show the asset for
you and also put in this
Google +1 button.
And again, the template snippet
is below if you want
to roll your own solution.
So in the app, we're requesting
the appropriate 300
by 250 size with the ad unit
that we set up in DFP, and we
get that ad.
Next example we have is Mobile
Interstitial with Auto-close.
This is very similar to the
interstitial example we showed
you on the DoubleClick for
Publishers bundled side,
except the advantage here is
that we can use a template
instead of having to hand
form our own code.
So in this example, we set a
target ad size, an image for
portrait, an image for
landscape, and a clickthrough
URL, as well as how long
we want to display this
interstitial before
we close it.
And we can set up this
interstitial.
The creative template
snippet is below.
That's essentially what we use
to build the bundled version
of this interstitial.
The downside of this specific
template is it does not allow
you to specify multiple
image assets for
different screen sizes.
So if you wanted to do what
we did in the regular
interstitial example, you're
still going to need to kind of
hand form your own creative.
But this is good to give
you just your basic--
in this case--
320 by 480 example.
And if you rotated your device
to landscape, it would give
you the landscape version
of this image.
Our bundled interstitial
example did not include
landscape assets.
And so there, you would see the
portrait asset in landscape.
So you would have to alter that
code if you wanted to get
this kind of effect.
Another template that
DFP premium
offers is Image Animation.
So with Image Animation, you
essentially set up an image
animation template and upload a
few images that you want to
move between.
You can decide how long each
one of those assets gets
displayed, how they're
transitioned and their
clickthrough URL.
And you get something that
looks like this.
We're going to serve this as
an interstitial, and we
provided 320 by 480 images.
And here, we have Honeycomb
images that are transitioning.
So again, you get this template
for free when you're
a premium publisher.
If you were doing this as a not
premium publisher, you'd
have to implement
this yourself.
I want to talk about the Video
Interstitial template.
For DFP premium, again, we
specify a default loading
image while the interstitial
is loading.
And then we just upload a video
file, and DFP will put
it in all the right formats
that you need for all
different devices.
You give it a destination URL,
and you can also add a couple
buttons on the bottom to
go to Google+ or post
to Facebook or Twitter.
And they all have clickthrough
URLs as well.
And using that template really
quick, you can get a video
interstitial.
So this is our image while the
video interstitial is loading.
And the video should
start playing.
Might be a little slow
one on the emulator.
You can also decide whether or
not this video interstitial
should auto close after
it's done playing.
So the last three templates
we have
here are custom templates.
This is very similar to the
basic image that we had on the
bundled side, except we wrote
our own code, but we're able
to write a template for it so
that we could keep reusing it
for different types
of creatives.
So this is a click
to download ad.
It's essentially just your
basic image except its
clickthrough URL is a Google
Play URL, so it will go to the
Google Play Store as opposed
to just a web browser.
We also set up an equivalent iOS
version that goes to the
Apple Store.
And the benefit of this type
of template that we set up
here is we allowed you to
specify a width and height,
and as well as an
image upload.
But you can upload, in this
case, a high-res image, like
640 by 100, and set the width
and height to be 320 by 50.
And the actual code here has an
image tag which takes the
big URL but specifically
sets the width and
height to 320 by 50.
So this allows you to
shoehorn, I guess, a
higher-res creative into
a smaller space.
And so for those bigger devices,
bigger res devices
that are actually 640 by 100,
you'll get that clear image.
So again, if you're a bundled
publisher or a small business
publisher, you can write
this code yourself.
You just won't be able to create
a template for it, and
every image you want to do high
res like this, you'll
have to, again, hand
form your own code.
So similarly for click to call,
it's using the exact
same template, high-res
images.
We have it set up 320 and 360 by
50 for both iPhones as well
as Androids with
bigger screens.
And the clickthrough URL in this
case is just a tel colon
with the telephone number.
Finally, the click to map.
Again, very similar.
Same 320 and 360 by
50 creatives.
I think I have the wrong
image set up here.
But the clickthrough URL will
be a Google Maps URL, and
it'll open up Google Maps.
So just to demo one for click
to map, it asks if you're
looking for coffee.
And it clicks through to Google
Maps which has a query
for coffee in Mountain View.
So it'll open up Maps.
It'll input your query, assuming
you put in the right
URL, and it'll do the search.
So these are all the creatives
that we have in
DFP Showcase V2.
I'm going to leave you with a
couple resources for how to
get started with this and some
other useful resources.
So the SDK download you can
find that developers.googl
e.com/mobile-ads-sdk/download.
I The DFP site where you can set
up your creatives is just
google.com/DFP.
If you want to set up AdMob
creatives or SDK mediation,
you can go to
google.com/ad/admob to log
into your AdMob account.
If you need help setting up
the native Android or iOS
code, you can go to our
developer docs at
developers.googl
e.com/mobile-ads
-sdk/docs/dfp/fundamentals.
We have a specific doc set,
especially for DFP.
If you have any questions, you
can ask us in our forum at
developers.googl
e.come/mobile-ad
s-sdk/community.
You can also see our Plus page
for all ads-related updates on
your Google Developer
products.
We also a blog.
You can search for the AdMob SDK
tag on our blog for cool
blog posts.
For code examples, like the v2
version of this app, it will
be hosted on code.google.com/
p/google-mobile-dev, our
Google Mobile Dev, Google
Code project.
And finally, for some sample
creatives if you're a small
business publisher, some
of these creatives like
interstitial with auto-close
and MRAID expandable, they
have some sample code from
those templates on this
support.google.com/dfp
small business site.
I would recommend that if you're
looking to do MRAID
expandables or kind of
writing your own code
and need some help.
So that's it.
I'm Eric Leichtenschlag.
Thanks for watching.